como sería el mundo sino compitiéramos
entre nosotros mismos
vamos a recordar aquellas enseñanzas de
nuestros padres cuando éramos niños
nuestros padres a muchos de nosotros nos
enseñaron nos enseñaron que debíamos ser
la mejor versión de nosotros mismos que
debemos de buscar ser siempre los
mejores para así cumplir nuestras metas
a nosotras además de eso también se nos
enseña que debemos de lucir de la mejor
manera
debemos de hablar de la mejor manera
debemos de reírnos de la mejor manera
sentarnos de la mejor manera y general
lucir como las mejores
conforme vamos creciendo
damos cuenta que los medios de
comunicación alaban esta misma enseñanza
diciéndonos que eres mejor mujer si
tienes un cabello hermoso tienes una
piel joven clara tersa tienes un cuerpo
delgado usas la mejor ropa y la luz es
de la mejor forma
todo esto nos lleva a crear un sistema
de competencia entre nosotros
así mismo de juzgarnos dentro de
nosotros por lo que si vemos a una mujer
que no se maquilla decimos que es fea si
vemos a una mujer que no se arregla lo
suficiente decimos que es floja si vemos
a una mujer que trabaja mucho
le decimos que es una intensa una adicta
al trabajo no importa que inclusive esté
trabajando por hacer sus sueños realidad
si llevamos esto a un extremo también
tenemos el caso de aquella mujer que si
se atreve a ir a hablarle a la persona
que le gusta es una atrevida a una
lanzada o unas horas
si vemos a una mujer que vive su
sexualidad libremente le decimos que es
una
lo peor del caso es que todo esto lo
decimos entre nosotras
los hombres tienen un código de valores
que no está escrito a ningún lado pero
lo saben está ahí intrínseco
es este código conocido como el brou
code o la hermandad que los hace
respetarse entre ellos
lo que han construido lo que han
trabajado lo que es suyo
en las mujeres también existe este
código y este código se llama sororidad
la sonoridad es este código de valores
que existe entre mujeres que no importa
de dónde vengas cuántos años tienes si
vives con tus papás de qué color tienes
el pelo si tienes tatuajes o piercings
eres mujer y yo soy mujer y entiendo por
lo que has pasado o estás pasando o vas
a pasar porque todavía en pleno 2017 las
mujeres no podemos ejercer con plenitud
nuestros derechos derechos como la
libertad de expresión derechos de
reproducción sexual derechos de la de
derechos educativos y derechos laborales
por eso te entiendo por eso te apoyo por
eso estamos juntas
para que me entiendan mejor vamos a
poner este ejemplo imaginemos que
estamos aquí todos en una gran fiesta
imaginemos que aquí está la barra hay
una chica sola está esperando a alguien
no importa quién se acerca un chico a
coquetearle y ella le hace notar que no
tiene interés en él el chico insiste y
la chica también
y luego le dice esta frase que todos
sabemos que alejan a cualquier hombre
tengo novia
en la mayoría de los casos esta frase va
a ser que el sujeto en cuestión se aleje
pero no se está alejando porque ya tenga
novio sino porque respeta que es la
novia de otro hombre
les voy a revelar en donde vivimos la
sororidad para aquellos que no saben lo
que pasa en el baño de mujeres
imaginemos esta misma fiesta pero vamos
a imaginarnos qué sucede adentro del
baño de mujeres
es el lugar donde sucede
no vemos normalmente
en el baño de mujeres todas somos amigas
somos aliadas no importa si tu vestido
está de moda o no no importa si viniste
con tu novio o te trajo tu papá no
importa en el baño de mujeres todas
somos amigas todas nos apoyamos nos
entendemos nos prestamos maquillaje nos
prestamos un pasador si lo necesita no
dejamos que alguien se salga del baño
con el vestido marcado le decimos y en
el vestido arregla tela
incluso si vemos a alguien alguna y
ahora g del baño nos acercamos y le
preguntamos si está bien le damos un
consejo nos convertimos en amigas
las invito a que de aquí en adelante
veamos el mundo como un gran baño de
mujeres
para empezar
llevamos olas siempre vamos acompañadas